cette semaine le monde de la mode a été
secoué par une collaboration inédite
entre une marque de luxe est une marque
de sportswear présenté dans un défilé
plutôt étrange
et oui tous ses mannequins revêtus de
leurs plus beaux latex ont présenté une
multitude de pièces à la foule mais
celle qui a retenu notre attention c'est
cette jolie paire de chaussettes
accessible pour la modique somme de 150
euros a three là pour de simples
chaussettes difficile de se dire s'ils
vont en découler beaucoup de stock en
tout cas il y en a un qui va sûrement
faire chauffer la carte bleue pour les a
prises et j'ai commandé
les a proposés oui tu les a commandées
oui me dégoûte
moi je comprends que ça puisse choquer
mais finalement si on proratisé c'est le
même chose que les toutes les pièces de
luxe c'est à dire qu'une chemise qui va
coûter 1500 euros un sac à main qui va
coûter huit mille euros c'est très
choquant si on ratisse finalement je
vous avais marre de sang proratisé
partout la chaussette et fulham m
chaussettes encore que la chaussée la
rajouter simplement le logo de la marque
supérieure celle email c'était celle
qu'on tue a permis c'est la même chose
pour les calculs d'un bal c'est la même
chose pour une casquette c'est la même
chose pour un tee shirt un simple
t-shirt d'une grande marque ge a coûté
800 euros 900 euros ce continent alors
que tu as du coton et que franchement
c'est n'y a pas de daniel toi ta chemise
je sais que c'est une grande marque
un gros match à faire mais il va tenter
quelques années
pour raison de dépôt de bilan
quel est le truc allez moi j'ai envie
qu'on se confie un peu quel est le truc
le plus cher est à combien vous avez
fait une folie vestimentaire voilà c'est
quoi le truc le plus cher quand vous
ayez acheté je sais toi tu sais quoi
c'est à moumoute
[Rires]
non c'est pas un vestimentaire faisait
que c'est pas pour toi c'est pour fatou
bâ oui bah
ouais on est quoi qu'on veuille me sens
un peu d'eau les revêtements bentonite
par earth utile va pas m a paru en slip
cd pareil c'est une paire de chaussures
que je vais acheter que j'ai offert non
aux impôts seulement le prix
alors c'était pour plusieurs fait
cumuler c'était au tour de 1000 euros
mais bon c'est plus
de 1000 euros là sociaux mais il en a
perdu
[Rires]
ça
g on va tirer ou pas là
vous tient daniel alors moi s'il ya très
très longtemps c'est en sept ans mais
déjà je commençais à travailler vrai il
est même pas j'avais 18 ans et je me
suis acheté une robe verte j'étais mince
à l'époque une belle revers pas exprès
pour faire aujourd'hui madame c'est une
émission tu vois tu peux nous dire des
trucs
avec le fameux jean le poulain en fait
et donc j ai trop dit à l'époque ça fait
je crois que ça mais je commence à peine
à travailler ça faisait deux trous deux
ou trois mois de salaire c'était un
sacrifice mois jacques roberge commencé
à travailler moi tu en as fait quoi dans
la fine tombe j'espérais
une pop quechua j'ai mis très longtemps
elle était très jolie j'ai des photos
avec un testeur regrette pas du tout à
du kram et ton candide quoi ouais t'as
du kram et d'oseille tenant j'ai fait
une folie une fois puisque la sht 5115
franc et j'avais acheté un bombardier
500 bons voire sur les quais de seine
dans le 6ème au front populaire du front
fait exactement je les connais voulait
pas dire la marque et et j'étais alors
on est obligé de citer d'autres marques
de cuir cuir elle la
cuillère
versant de terre mélangée à du gras et
cuir que m'attire c'était une vraie
folie parce que là par rapport à mon
salaire c'était une vraie folie bassin
1500 bull pour amuser la hachette une
voiture à ce prix là il roulait le
besoin rouler défense
tu peux alors eh ouais alors toi tu sais
pas cette chemise bleu clair non
pourtant les gens mais justement par
exemple le prix de cette chemise il est
très choquant par rapport à la gts est
choquant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour la pièce la plus chère ça doit
être une veste en cuir et du coup ça
doit être aux alentours de 5000 mais
euros quoi mais après c'est une garde et
où bien sûr à une pièce en cuir et bien
sûr moi j'ai pris leur idole l'animal
avec un rein
j'ai dit à ce prix là vous me donnez à
l'image de l'animal à la maison je le
chouchouter sans déconner énorme élan
récit abbassi je suis sûr que guillaume
van détrôner ça va être la cc66
une veste à paillettes que j'ai payé
très cher une veste à paillettes et
qu'on allait lâcher c'était quand
c'était pour qu'elle a occasion je me
suis fait pigeonner par un vendeur
c'était à new york
quand on veille à l'ensemble ouais
heureusement je suis beau nul tombe bien
alors qu'en bien merlin 15000 euros
le texte a dit quoi on en anglais là il
fait 10 fois quand marie médiatique est
omis de chailly
cette mère dont il a tu l'as dit hamid
al antenne 2 3 fois à l'antenne on l'a
même pas remarqué
non mais t'es con comme une valise mais
sans déconner vous alors moi je suis pas
fou moi je suis franchement moi je suis
jamais de folie benjamin le say what u
les achètent pas surtout
les chroniqueurs cb
je vois que c'est faux un truc je sais
pas de folies mon nom mais ils achètent
donc tomber deux trois trucs c'est pas
autorisé pas ou feint non match où sa
puissance est rendu compte surtout
m'énerve à moi tu mets un style une
paire de chaussettes fait tout l'été
sur la plage suis tranquille mais sans
déconner je
te le dis moi moi moi j'ai déjà vous
dire le poids et et et ça va vous
arriver quand tu arrives à un niveau
physique et tu peux t'en sais une chose
c'est le tessin berne a été tranquille
tu es bien dans ta tête et bien dans ta
peau tu es bien noter la belle
étoile tout est au taquet statut te
c'est lui qui est de faire le record sur
qu il aille est capable d'aller acheter
un truc de fou il ya très longtemps
c'était un besoin de cuire qui m'a valu
les premières brouille avec vous parce
que je faisais beaucoup de photos avec
et vous laisser un commentaire sur mon
blouson en cuir tiago est ce bouffon
depuis lausanne à acheter je n'ai jamais
dit ça il se voit trop tard et aurillac
et or et ce besoin des nobles d'une très
belle marque et écoutez nous ferait une
tonne dix mois
mélina des 15 mai c'est pas plus en plus
probable aux enfers m chaque les besoins
il faisait avions si tu mets des corps
ça
[Musique]
c'est horrible c'est même très très très
très beau jeu
vidéo même acheté à monaco et l'as
monaco la leçon que la
ola laquelle bond de pigeons sans
rigoler que vous baissez ça
c'est assez pour faire des conneries